Ni siquiera soy ese tipo más sofisticado de voluptuosa o curvilínea.
Sin eufemismos,
soy G-O-R-D-A y punto.
Soy el elefante en la sala.
Cuando salí al escenario,
algunos habrán pensado:
"Seguro va a ser delirante,
porque todos saben que los gordos son graciosos".
(Risas)
O puede que hayan pensado: "¿De dónde saca la autoestima?"
Porque una gorda con autoestima es casi impensable.
Los interesados en la moda
habrán pensado lo fabulosa que me veo
con este vestido de Beth Ditto...
(Ovación)
muchas gracias.
Mientras que alguno puede que piense:
"Hmm, en negro se vería mucho más delgada".
(Risas)
Es posible que se hayan preguntado, de manera consciente o no,
si tengo diabetes o si tengo pareja,
o si como carbohidratos después de las 19 hs.
(Risas)
Puede haberles preocupado que comieron carbohidratos después de las 19 hs,
y que deberían renovar la membresía en el gimnasio.
Estos juicios son insidiosos.
Pueden ser dirigidos a individuos y grupos,
y también pueden dirigirse a nosotros mismos.
Y esta forma de pensar se conoce como gordofobia.
Como cualquier forma de opresión sistemática,
la gordofobia está profundamente arraigada en estructuras complejas
como el capitalismo, el patriarcado y el racismo,
y eso puede hacerlo realmente difícil de identificar,
por no decir un desafío.
Vivimos en una cultura
en la que ser gordo es visto como ser una mala persona...
perezosa, codiciosa, insalubre, irresponsable
y moralmente sospechosa.
Y tendemos a ver la delgadez
como algo universalmente bueno,
responsable, exitoso,
y en control de nuestros apetitos, cuerpos y vidas.
Vemos estas ideas una y otra vez
en los medios, en la política de salud pública,
en consultorios médicos,
en conversaciones cotidianas
y en nuestras propias actitudes.
Incluso podemos culpar a los gordos
por la discriminación a la que se enfrentan
porque, después de todo, si no nos gusta, deberíamos bajar de peso.
Fácil.
Este sesgo antigordo se ha vuelto tan integral, tan arraigado
de cómo nos autovaloramos y nos valoramos unos a otros
que rara vez nos preguntamos por qué tenemos tanto desprecio por los gordos
y de dónde viene ese desdén.
Pero debemos cuestionarlo,
porque el valor enorme que le damos al aspecto
nos afecta a todos.
¿Realmente queremos vivir en una sociedad
en la que se le niegue a la gente su humanidad básica
si no suscribe a alguna forma arbitraria de lo aceptable?
Así que cuando tenía seis años,
mi hermana solía enseñar ballet a un grupo de niñas en nuestro garaje.
Yo era 30 cm más alta y más ancha que la mayoría del grupo.
Cuando estábamos por hacer nuestra primera actuación,
estaba muy entusiasmada con ponerme un hermoso tutú rosa.
Iba a brillar.
Mientras las otras chicas se deslizaban con facilidad entre la lycra y los tules,
ningún tutú me quedaba bien.
Estaba decidida a no perderme la actuación,
así que miré a mi madre
y en voz alta para que oyeran todos
dije, "Mamá, no necesito un tutú -2,2-
necesito un fourfour" -4,4-
(Risas)
Gracias, mamá.
(Aplausos)
Y si bien no lo reconocía en ese momento,
hacerme espacio en ese glorioso fourfour
fue el primer paso hacia la activista radical de la gordura.
Ahora bien, no digo que todo este amor al cuerpo
ha sido fácil a lo largo de un brillante camino de autoaceptación
desde ese día en clase.
Lejos de eso.
Pronto aprendí que vivir fuera de lo que el común considera normal
puede ser algo frustrante y aislante.
He pasado los últimos 20 años desarmando y desprogramando estos mensajes,
y ha sido una montaña rusa.
Se han reído de mí, recibí insultos de autos que pasaban,
y me han dicho que soy desilusionante.
También he recibido sonrisas de extraños
que reconocen lo que se requiere para caminar por la calle
con paso firme y cabeza en alto.
(Ovación)
Gracias.
Y a través de todo, esa feroz pequeña de seis años se ha quedado conmigo,
y me ha ayudado a pararme frente a Uds. hoy
como gorda sin culpa,
una persona que simplemente se niega a suscribirse
a la narrativa dominante
sobre cómo debería moverme por el mundo con este cuerpo mío.
(Aplausos)
Y no estoy sola.
Soy parte de una comunidad internacional
que elige, en vez de aceptar pasivamente,
que nuestros cuerpos son grandes y quizá siempre lo serán,
y elegimos activamente florecer con estos cuerpos como son hoy.
Personas que honramos nuestra fuerza y trabajamos con, y no en contra,
de nuestras limitaciones percibidas;
personas que valoramos la salud
como algo mucho más holístico
que un número en un gráfico de IMC obsoleto.
Valoramos la salud mental, la autoestima y cómo nos sentimos con el cuerpo
como aspectos vitales del bienestar general.
Personas que se niegan a creer que vivir con estos cuerpos gordos
es una barrera para cualquier cosa, en realidad.
Hay médicos, académicos y blogueros
que han escrito ingentes volúmenes
sobre las muchas facetas de este complejo tema.
Hay fatshionistas que recuperan sus cuerpos y su belleza,
que lucen fatkinis y tops,
que exponen la carne que nos han enseñado a ocultar.
Hay atletas gordos
que corren maratones, que enseñan yoga o hacen kickboxing,
y lo hacen todo con el dedo medio apuntando al statu quo.
Y esta gente me ha enseñado que las políticas radicales del cuerpo
son el antídoto para la cultura de vergüenza por el cuerpo.
Pero para ser claros, no digo que la gente no deba cambiar sus cuerpos
si es lo que desea hacer.
Reivindicarse a sí mismo puede ser uno de los más hermosos actos de amor propio
y puede adoptar un millón de formas diferentes,
desde peinados hasta tatuajes y contorno corporal
desde hormonas hasta cirugía y sí, incluso hasta la pérdida de peso.
Es simple: es tu cuerpo,
tú decides lo mejor para hacer con él.
Mi forma de participar en el activismo
es haciendo todas las cosas que los gorditos se supone que no hacen,
y hay muchas cosas,
e invito a otras personas a sumarse y hacer arte con eso.
El hilo común de la mayor parte de este trabajo
ha sido reclamar espacios a menudo prohibitivos para cuerpos más grandes,
desde la pasarela hasta los clubes,
desde las piscinas públicas hasta las pistas de baile.
Y recuperar espacios en masa no es solo una poderosa declaración artística
sino un enfoque radical de construcción de comunidad.
Esto fue así en "AQUAPORKO!"...
(Risas)
el equipo gordo de danza acuática sincronizada
que creé con un grupo de amigos en Sídney.
El impacto de ver un puñado de gordas desafiantes
con gorros y trajes de baño floreados
lanzando sus piernas al aire sin preocupaciones,
no debería subestimarse.
(Risas)
En mi carrera, aprendí que los cuerpos gordos son inherentemente políticos,
y que los cuerpos gordos sin culpas
pueden hacer alucinar a la gente.
Cuando la directora Kate Champion,
de la aclamada compañía de teatro de danza Force Majeure,
me pidió que sea la asociada artística
en una obra que destacaba a bailarines gordos,
literalmente me lancé a la oportunidad.
Literalmente.
"Nada que perder" es una obra hecha en colaboración con actores gordos
que a partir de sus experiencias de vida
crean una obra tan variada y auténtica como somos todos.
Y fue tan distante del ballet como podrían imaginar.
La propia idea de obra de danza gorda con una compañía tan prestigiosa
fue, para decirlo suavemente, polémico,
porque nunca se había hecho nada semejante en los escenarios principales de la danza
en ningún lugar del mundo.
La gente era escéptica.
"¿Qué quieres decir con 'bailarines gordos'?"
¿Tamaño XL, XXL?
¿Dónde hicieron su entrenamiento de baile?
¿De dónde sacarán la resistencia para una producción de tan larga duración?"
Pero a pesar del escepticismo,
"Nada que perder", se volvió un éxito en el Festival de Sídney.
Recibimos críticas favorables, viajamos,
ganamos premios y fue escrita en más de 27 idiomas.
Estas increíbles imágenes de nuestro elenco fueron vistas en todo el mundo.
He perdido la cuenta de cuántas veces personas de todos los tamaños
me han dicho que el show les ha cambiado la vida,
de cómo les ayudó a cambiar su relación
con sus cuerpos y con los cuerpos de los demás,
y cómo les hizo enfrentarse a sus propios sesgos.
Pero, claro, una obra que mueve la fibra íntima
también tiene detractores.
Me han dicho que glorifico la obesidad.
He recibido amenazas de muerte violentas
y abuso por hacer una obra que se centra en la vida y el cuerpo de los obesos
y nos trata como seres valiosos con historias que valen la pena contar.
Me han llamado incluso
"el ISIS de la epidemia de obesidad"...
(Risas)
Un comentario que de tan absurdo es gracioso.
Pero también habla del pánico,
del terror literal,
que el miedo a la gordura puede evocar.
Es ese miedo alimentado por la industria de la dieta,
que nos mantiene a muchos sin hacer las paces con nuestros propios cuerpos,
esperando a ser la pos-foto
antes de empezar a vivir verdaderamente nuestras propias vidas.
Porque el verdadero elefante en la sala es la gordofobia.
El activismo gordo se niega a complacer este miedo.
Al abogar por la autodeterminación y el respeto por todos nosotros,
podemos cambiar el rechazo de la sociedad a abrazar la diversidad
y empezar a celebrar el montón de maneras que existen de tener un cuerpo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)